c'est un patron de bar il est dans son
bar tranquille et il y a un mec qui
rentre voilà et les mec qui rentre comme
ça et il dit moi je voudrais un whisky
et je paye pas parce que j'ai peur de
personne
un mec il a un petit le patron de marine
un peu petit et tout comme ça le mec est
grand et tout fais chier bon
allez vas-y c'est qu'un whisky je sors
son whisky l'autre il boit son whisky il
se barre son pays oh lendemain
rebelote le métier là ouais moi je
voudrais le whisky je paye pas parce que
j'ai peur de personne
vers le whisky mais je tiens c'est la
dernière fois tu m'as celui-là je
te jure donc il bat il boit le verre de
whisky le mec se barre il appelle un
petit attends j'ai un mec qui me fait
chier tous les jours ça fait deux fois
qui vient déjà euh il a peut-être son
pote le plus bas est-ce qu'il existe le
plus bas les armes mais que 2 m 125 kg
une masse vas-y viens Jojo tu t'attends
le mec je joue au bar le mec qui arrive
moi je veux un verre de whisky je paye
pas parce que j'ai peur de personne là
Jojo il se retourne fais-moi non plus
j'ai peur de personne
[Applaudissements]